welcome to exploring computing
today's video is human computer
interaction
human computer interaction or hci is an
important field of study in computer
science
it focuses on how to improve
interactions between humans and
computers
and the computers that you are working
on today
are a good sign of the success of
hci because hci is responsible for
things like the windows icon mouse and
pointer or wimp interface that we're all
using
and the fact that you are all using
graphical user interfaces instead of
command line interfaces where we're
typing out the computer
shows that hci researchers have had a
huge impact
on our world hot topics
currently in ati include virtual and
augmented reality
speech commands gestures where you're
using your hands to
interact with the computer and hci
researchers are even studying
brain computer interfaces one thing i
always like to point out when i'm
teaching my class is because i teach a
lot of
non-computer science students is that
there's a lot of different fields out
there that are actually
very important for hci work and some of
you may be studying these fields right
now
and so one of those is psychology i
psychology
is directly related to hci in a number
of different ways
for one thing having a better
understanding of human cognition can
lead to better applications so
things like how do humans perceive
colors
or what are the limitations of human
memory should be driving
our applications in addition
psychological research
has a lot of similarities with computer
science
user interface research and so in the
basement of the psychology building
there's a bunch of rooms where we bring
in
intro to psych students and uh ask them
to perform tasks
and on the other side of a one-way glass
mirror
uh we've got psych grad students who are
watching how they carry out those tasks
hci researchers do the exact same thing
in large computer science companies so
we have the same rooms with the one-way
glass we've got a computer set up there
we bring in some test subjects and we
ask them to carry out tasks
on our computer and we see how they're
actually interacting with the computer
whether they're able to use the computer
the way we expect
and typically again for the larger
companies we will actually have
psychologists
uh on staff who understand how to run
these experiments properly
another important related field is
graphic design
and uh and you know when i was working
industry we had a bunch of people from
uh from art schools who were working on
staff
specifically to work on hci work um
obviously ergonomics is super important
and then sociology and ethnography and
other related fields are also
really important for hci i think
particularly now
that so many of the applications are
designed for multiple people to use and
how
to help groups interact the importance
of sociologists is of course really
obvious there but
another way in which sociologists and
ethnographers are
really important is if we're asked to go
in and help
improve a particular workplace
we need sociologists and ethnographers
to go in and study that workplace and
have a good understanding of what's
going on in that workplace
before we can help automate and
computerize that workplace
let's take a quick look at some of the
things that user interface
experts do when they're trying to design
a new ui
the first thing you should do is some
need finding we want to determine what
the user's actual needs are
and so we're going to spend some time
observing the workplace uh studying the
current processes
and interviewing potential users we're
then going to
determine what the different roles
within that workplace are and what the
different tasks that are regularly
carried out in that workspace
and then we're going to do some
prototyping we're going to do some
testing of those prototypes and then
we're going to iterate this last part is
really important because it turns out
that
we aren't particularly good at coming up
with
programs that actually help in the
workplace and so
it's very important that not only do we
interview people
and come up with ideas based on what the
feedback that they're
giving us in the interviews are but that
we test them out and try them again it's
actually not
uncommon for users to think that they
want
a program and then when they actually
try out the program to realize
oh this isn't as helpful as i thought i
think maybe what we really want is this
other thing
and so that process of iteration where
you
work in conjunction with your potential
users
to try out different things and
ultimately really identify what they
actually need as opposed to what their
initial perceived
concerns are is super important the
prototypes you can build
range in quality from low fidelity to
high fidelity or is there sometimes
referred to
low fight to hifi and so examples
include
a very low fidelity paper sketches where
you just draw
diagrams on on a piece of paper
now these can still be used for user
interface experiments so you can
talk to people about the process by
which they go from
one uh diagram showing a particular
window and you know
hey where would you where would you
click on this window
uh you know which buttons do you think
you should use
um two wireframes which are done on the
computer but
where we're not concerned with uh
details
that we would be on a real application
such as colors and fonts
but the the wireframe still gives us a
good idea of what sort of information
might be on that screen
and we can have a mock-up a higher
quality mock-up
with the fonts and the colors and other
things actually worked in
and then we can have higher fidelity
prototypes where
the user can actually interact with them
and press certain buttons and so
the way this might work is suppose we
are
working on an online bookstore an
example we'll use in more detail in a
minute
and we could tell somebody hey go ahead
and interact with our
high fidelity mockup here and look up a
book on
say south american history and so the
user would
hopefully find the correct text field to
enter in their search phrase and type
south american history and they would
hit
return and we would move to another
screen that showed the results of
looking for south american history
but the key thing that's going on here
is it doesn't really matter what you
type in that text field
when you click on the search button it
only goes to results of south american
history because
that's the only thing we have it
hardwired for so here you've got a
prototype that that looks real and has
some interaction but
isn't the same as a real program it's
much much more simplified
so these higher fidelity prototypes can
give better results but
they are somewhat problematic because it
turns out that the more time and effort
a team puts into creating
uh these prototypes the harder it is for
them to
take results that suggest that that high
fidelity
prototype that they spent all that time
on is in fact the wrong approach
uh it's much harder to toss it out if
the only thing you've done is drawn some
diagrams
on a piece of paper and you start
interacting with users and
finding out that hey your ideas are
wrong it's relatively
low cost to toss out those paper
diagrams and come up with another set of
paper diagrams
i don't want to discount the cost of
making paper diagrams having
spent uh so much time um making some of
the diagrams for
for these lectures they are actually
fairly time consuming but
uh nevertheless uh it's much less time
consuming to come up with those diagrams
whether they're done on paper or on the
computer
than it is to actually have interactive
prototypes
i mentioned we're going to talk a little
bit about a bookstore so i want to do a
little
case study to sort of walk you through
some of the things that we should be
thinking about
if we're designing a new program
so in this particular case i suppose the
tas and i got together and we decided
that
we wanted to do a new startup and we
thought the best idea for
a new startup was to create an online
bookstore that seems like a great idea
and i don't think anybody's done that
right so
so let's let's see how we could walk
through the process of creating this
online bookstore
okay so we need to be thinking about who
our users are
and remember what i said earlier we
wanted to be thinking about the roles
and the tasks
and for this particular video i'm just
going to focus on our interaction with
customers but
if we were going to do this for real
there would be a whole nother set of
tasks involved with the employees of the
bookstore
but we're just going to focus on the
customers so we want to be thinking
about
who our website visitors are
why they're visiting the website what
their level of technical expertise is
what sort of devices do they have and
what their
internet connections look like how fast
are they how reliable are they things
like that
and then we want to think about
different tasks that
they might want to interact with our
website for so
the obvious one is i'm looking for a
particular book
but that's not the only reason why
somebody might come to the website
they might be interested in a particular
topic but not be interested in a
specific book
or not have an idea of a specific book
associated with that topic and this is
really a key distinction
um i think the stanford library has
gotten better at this but for a long
time
they had a great interface when you were
looking for a specific book it would
tell you
uh hey here's the book um here's which
library it's located in
here's how many copies we have uh here's
how long that copy is checked out for
and here's what it's going to be
available next
um and so that was super useful but when
it came to
i've got a topic i'm interested in but i
don't know a specific book
in that topic it was a horrible horrible
interface
and so you need to think carefully about
you know what
are all the reasons why somebody might
visit our little bookstore here
and you want to think carefully about
how to meet each of those needs
and then here's the third need down here
at the bottom you know they might be
sitting in class
and they might be bored and you know if
they want to come visit our website
every time they go to their exploring
computing class
we would be happy for them to do that we
want to find new and interesting content
to show them each day
have some idea of the sorts of things
they're interested in and
you know find nice glossy ways of
presenting
those books to them so that they come by
frequently
and hopefully get excited about
something we show them and ultimately
buy them
so these are three very different uh
reasons why somebody might visit our
website and
the sorts of things we might need to do
on our website to meet
each of these three different tasks are
actually quite different so you need to
think carefully
why are people here not just you know
what is the minimum sort of thing that
somebody might need in order to come to
our website but try and be
as expansive as possible that's going to
give you a broader
uh range of audiences and that's going
to give you an overall better website
and then what we might want to do is
come up with
information on potential customers and
keeping in mind that there are lots of
different people visiting our website
and they're all going to have different
characteristics and so one strategy that
is often used it's actually
come up with user personas so here are
some
potential customers nikki is a young
professional she visits a website on her
cell phone
she has moderate internet speeds on her
um but she often visits on her way
home from work and the internet
connection on our bus ride home is often
kind of spotty
patrick is a senior citizen he has low
technical expertise
and visits the website on a windows 95
laptop
so you know do we want to support him
his web browser is likely to be pretty
old
and he might have some security issues
because
windows 95 is no longer supported by
microsoft
and that's actually a good point so you
do need to think about
you know what range of people are you
going to support
because the more people you support um
you know as we've talked a little bit
with the html and css
the more likely you are to run into
problems with their web browser the less
compatible their web browser is and the
the fewer the cool css stuff that you're
going to be able to do is
i'm going back to patrick our senior
citizen here though
and so he has a really old laptop but he
does have a good internet connection
and then maddie is a junior high school
student she's got moderate technical
skills
she's got a low end tablet uh but she
does have good internet connection
and so the idea here is we can think
about the different tasks that uh
we identified customers potentially
doing on the website
and then in our meetings when we're
discussing the design we can actually
bring up these personas so we can say
okay this seems like a interesting
design
and i could see how nikki would be able
to figure out how to use it but
what about patrick would patrick be able
to figure this out
or you know if we were thinking about
the sorts of information displayed on
our website you might ask
would nikki be able to see this part of
the website well on her commute home
and if we're taking up too much
bandwidth for her to do that
how are we going to provide her with an
alternative so creating these different
personas and giving them names gives us
a way to talk about these
sorts of users when we're in our in our
meetings
and then we want to do user testing and
so as if we've talked about before
you're going to have
different prototypes of different
quality and you're probably going to
want to start off with the low-fi
prototypes
because the hi-fi prototypes take a lot
of time and effort to get
in so you know spend some time with the
lo-fi prototypes and if it looks like
you're in the right direction you can go
ahead and refine them and come up with
more and more higher quality prototypes
um you need to get a bunch of
users who are not directly involved with
the project
and in fact you might want to try and
get users that match your personas
so you know if we think we're going to
have senior citizens visiting our
website
who are using windows 95 laptops
try and get some older users who maybe
don't have a lot of technical expertise
um bring them in uh sit them down in
front of
your prototype whatever level of
prototyping you're doing
and ask them how to carry a particular
task say okay
suppose you're presented with a screen
here
try to find the new bestseller by jane
cardinal
how do you think you would do that with
this screen and so you know whether
they're presented with a paper prototype
and hopefully
if it's a good drawing they can sort of
look it over and say
oh i see how this would translate to a
real computer program
i think you know they could tap on the
piece of paper and say
oh i think i would uh i would enter
something into this text field or if
it's a
high fidelity prototype they can
actually interact with it they see the
text field there
they can click their mouse on it and
they can go ahead and enter that
information there
all right we could ask them suppose
you're looking for a book on south
american history
what would you do and they could take a
look at your
prototypes and figure out exactly how
they would interact with it
so aci as i said is a really important
field in computer science
and it's a great place for people that
may not have
a strong computer science background to
get involved with helping to develop
computer products and programs
you